- But here's one of
the fundamental things
I think people
need to understand
about what Liz Cheney is doing,
is, we have a
separation of powers.
The legislative branch
writes the laws,
the executive branch
carries them out,
and the judiciary
makes decisions,
from criminal law
to criminal cases,
to deciding disputes
between neighbors.
What this commission has
done is taken on the role
of all of them, but
most importantly,
this January 6th Commission
is acting as the prosecutor.
They're presenting evidence to
themselves as the judiciary,
and then they are going
to be making the decision
as the jury, so they have
actually subsumed in themselves
all aspects of decision-making.
They will decide what
evidence comes in,
and if it doesn't fit their
narrative, we'll never see it,
it'll never see
the light of day.
(somber music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a US congressional candidate
for Wyoming's at-large District.
Harriet Hageman, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you so much
for having me, Dave.
It's wonderful to be here.
- I'm glad to have you
because we met briefly
about two weeks ago
at a fundraiser at
Peter Thiel's house
and you were gonna give a
talk and then unfortunately,
sometimes it does
rain here in Miami,
and it started to rain,
so you had to cut your
talk just a bit short,
but I thought there's
something interesting.
This lady's up to something,
I liked what you
started talking about,
you're running
against Liz Chaney,
there's a lot there, so
I thought, first off,
how about you just introduce
yourself to the people,
since Wyoming,
obviously, a small state,
but an important one,
but for the people
that don't know you.
- Well, I appreciate
that opportunity.
Yes, I was going to give
a bit more background
about who I was.
It was a wonderful
event at Peter's home,
and so many of the people
there had never met me before,
so I wanted to give them
just a bit of background
so that they knew who they
were supporting and why.
We oftentimes focus on the fact
that I'm running
against Liz Cheney,
but I'm not just running
I'm running for Wyoming.
I have deep, deep
roots in Wyoming.
I, my great-grandfather
came to Wyoming
in 1879 on a cattle
trail north from Texas,
and he ended up ranching
there for many, many years,
and so I have lots of cousins,
I have a very large
family here in Wyoming,
and then I come from
a large family myself.
When I was born, I was
my parents' fifth child.
When they brought me
home from the hospital,
my oldest sister
was five years old
and they had just
bought a ranch,
they were over $200,000 in debt,
they had $35 in the
bank and it was 1962,
so we were land-rich,
I guess, you'd say,
but awfully cash-poor.
I grew up on that ranch.
I grew up fixing
fence and moving cows
and flipping bales and doing
whatever was necessary.
We all learned to drive when
we were about four years old
because we helped our dad
when he was feeding cows.
We were very actively involved
and our parents
ensured that we were,
and one of the things
that they always taught us
when we were growing up,
and I know that this sounds
a bit strange to some people
who don't grow up in
that kind of a life,
but my parents always told us
that we had a responsibility
to keep ourselves alive.
From the time we were
very, very young,
three and four years old,
we were told, we had to
keep ourselves alive.
They didn't put a lot
of constraints on us.
We rode horseback,
we did things,
we would be gone from the house
for six, seven hours a day,
we played with snapping turtles,
we had a rattlesnake that
lived under the house
for a period of time,
we did a lot of things out
there, but we, but with that,
we had a lot of freedom, I
guess, is what I'm saying,
and so the flip side of
freedom is responsibility
and the flip side of
responsibility is freedom,
and right now in this country,
that isn't really the way
that people view things,
and I think Thomas Sowell
recently said it best
when he said, people are
no longer responsible
for themselves, but
they're responsible
for what other people did,
even if it was a
hundred years ago,
and I think that that's where
we're heading in this country,
and I think it's a
really wrong approach,
and I think that that's
why my background
really helps me to understand
because that freedom
is incredibly important
and it's part of
why I'm running.
So in terms of my background,
I'm a water and natural
resource attorney,
I'm a constitutional attorney,
I've been practicing
law for almost 33 years,
and I've been fighting for
and working for Wyoming
for a long, long time.
I work and I fight
for the people
who put food on your table,
gas in your car or
roof over your head,
and they pave your highways.
And so I have the credentials,
I have the background,
I have the knowledge
about Wyoming
to be an effective
Congresswoman for the state,
but also, you mentioned that
Wyoming is an important state,
it's an incredibly
important state
to the prosperity
of this country.
We're the Saudi Arabia
of the United States.
We're the largest coal producer,
we're the largest
trona producer,
we're one of the top oil and
gas producers in the nation.
We really are instrumental
in terms of ensuring
prosperity in this country,
and so that's why it is
so incredibly important
to have someone
with my background,
my history and my knowledge
running for this seat,
because I need to
do it for Wyoming,
and I also need to
do for our country.
- You know, it's funny, you
said it quite well there,
but when I was listening
to you talk at Peter's,
I was thinking, this
is really something,
cuz you were saying a
little bit about your bio
and I'm thinking, here
I am, I'm Brooklyn born,
lived in New York
City most of my life,
then Los Angeles for
the last eight years
until I moved here to the
free state of Florida,
and yet the things that
you're talking about right now
are exactly the things
that resonate with me
and that shows you how
the ideas of freedom
and liberty and all
of that crazy stuff
really has nothing
to do with geography.
People just don't
understand the issues.
So one thing that I saw,
and I didn't know
this till this morning
when I was doing a
little research on you,
that Wyoming's
at-large district,
meaning there is only one
congressional district
in the entire state.
That is really, is that the
only state to have that?
I think so.
- I think so.
And we're the least populated
state in the nation,
so we only have 560,000
people in our state,
but we're the ninth
largest land-wise.
So I've already traveled,
since September,
I've already driven
over 13,000 miles
in the state of Wyoming
visiting every single county,
sometimes multiple
times, going to events.
Last Wednesday, I was at
a bull sale in Worland
and meeting with our ranchers,
meeting with our
cattle producers,
talking to them
about the challenges
associated with
the supply chain,
oh, my goodness gracious,
trying to get parts
for our tractors,
for our trucks
to be able to haul
our livestock.
All of those things
are being impacted
by this horrific administration
that we have in place
right now with Joe Biden,
Nancy Pelosi and the
radical Democrats.
We feel it in Wyoming,
you feel it in New York,
you feel it in Florida,
we feel it everywhere
in this country
cuz this is a disaster
that has been created
in large part because
the very first thing
that Biden did
when he took office
was try to choke off
our energy supply.
That affects me
personally in Wyoming
because again, we're an
energy producing state,
but affects every
single one of us,
and just, I've been having
to eat out quite a bit lately
cuz I am traveling so much.
The cost of food in restaurants
is absolutely skyrocketing.
I had a breakfast the
other day at the airport,
realized it's bit
expensive at the airport,
a pork chop, couple of eggs,
a cup of coffee, a
cup of tea, it's $33.
Now, that's just astronomical.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And it is because of
this administration.
- So you mentioned that you guys
are an energy producing
state, obviously.
Can you just talk a little
bit about the type of people
that are in that line of work,
the people that are
in the coal mines,
et cetera, et cetera,
that are doing this stuff
because I think people,
especially out of the
mainstream left now
and what you get at AOC
and the rest of them,
is just a complete
dismissal of these people
and their lives and
the work that they do
and how, you mentioned
generational,
how many years they've put
into this and everything else,
can you just talk about
the types of people
that are your
hopeful constituents?
- Well, absolutely.
They are the salt of the earth,
they're independent,
they're tough,
they know who and what we
are in the state of Wyoming,
they understand
our constitution,
and they really do understand
freedom and liberty
cuz they live it every day.
They do what they wanna do
and they produce a
fabulous resource.
So many people
wanna write coal off
and say that coal is
an energy of the past.
That's absolutely stupid,
and it's stupid for
a lot of reasons.
One is, coal is
abundant, it's clean,
it is accessible,
it's affordable,
it is absolutely an
energy of the future,
and we are the largest coal
producer in the nation.
Japan, China, they're building
coal-fired power plants
like there's no tomorrow.
The reality is, is that we
have to have fossil fuels
or people are gonna die.
They're gonna die in
the summer from heat,
they're gonna die in
the winter from cold,
and that's why I'm very
proud of what Wyoming does
cuz we make everybody's
lives better.
When you flip on that switch,
there's an awfully good
chance that that electricity
is coming from my state cuz
it's coming from our coal.
So these are great people
and it is intergenerational.
It's interesting,
several years ago,
I took a tour of the trona
mines over in Wyoming,
and trona is a baking soda
and what you use to make flat
glass and that sort of thing,
and I took a tour of that
and the number of men
who followed their
mothers into the mines,
or followed their
fathers into the mines.
We don't often think of
women of being minors,
but in Wyoming,
they absolutely are.
They're the heavy
equipment operators.
They are very actively
involved in the industry,
and I love meeting
with folks like that.
Up in Gillette, just absolutely
a wonderful area to visit.
You go up there and you can see
the magnitude of what
we produce in Wyoming,
again, with our oil
and gas, with our CBM.
Cold bed methane was
something we produced
a lot of earlier this century,
and then also our coal.
Same with ranchers.
We're a very independent
people in Wyoming.
What we really want
is we want the right
and the ability to make the
decisions for ourselves.
We don't need the government
telling us what to do.
We don't need the
government telling us
to put mask on our kids.
We look at what's going
on with the truckers
in Canada and we support them.
Those are the
people who make sure
that you have canned goods
in your grocery store,
that you have meat in
your grocery store.
Everybody in this country
ought to be supporting them,
and if this hadn't
become so political
over all of the
coronavirus hysteria,
we all would be supporting them
because they're standing
up for what's right,
they're standing up
for independence,
they're standing
up for all of us.
And I'm very, very
proud of them.
I'm proud of the folks
in the United States
who are doing the same thing.
I have a nephew who's trying
to get into the
tracking business,
and he's now purchased
two 18-wheelers,
and just trying to get the parts
and get delivery on things.
It's about to crush him,
and this is a 28 year old kid.
He's got three daughters.
He's absolutely the most
wonderful person in the world,
and here you've got
an administration
that's doing everything
in their power
to make it so that he can't
succeed in that business.
And one of the
things I often talk
about when I talk
about my upbringing,
and the fact that I did come
from pretty humble beginnings,
is, it's only in
the United States
that we've always had
the freedom to succeed.
And we now have
an administration
and a group of people who
don't want us to succeed.
They wanna dictate who
prospers and who does not,
and that is not America,
that isn't what we stand for.
We all have the
freedom to succeed
no matter what we came from.
- So jumping back for a second,
you mentioned sort
of small population,
sixth largest state
geographically.
Related to the COVID situation,
everyone thinks, okay,
Florida did it so right.
I'm a living example of that.
That's why I moved here.
People don't really talk
about Wyoming related to that.
What was it like in
the midst of all this
because you've got a sort
of limited amount of people
and a lot of space and
yet you have people in DC
telling you, okay, six
feet, mask, everybody,
et cetera, et cetera?
- Well, you had
Washington, DC, doing it,
but I'm also going
to be critical
of some of the leaders
right here in Wyoming.
One of the things that I think
too many governors did is,
they turned over public policy
to public health workers.
And you don't ever
turn up public,
turn over your public
policy responsibility
to a group of people that
only have a very narrow focus
of everything that they
do, and our governor did,
and so we had some
of the mask mandates.
We had some of the limiting
in terms of our schools
and keeping kids outta schools
and shutting down businesses,
and it shouldn't have
happened in Wyoming.
You listen to your
public health experts,
but you also listen
to your economists,
you also listen to your
small business owners,
you also listen
to your educators
and you also listen
to your parents.
And if you pick just
one of those and say,
okay, Dr. Fauci, you're gonna
be the king of all things
right now as we figure this out,
you're creating a disaster,
and we've lived it.
Dr. Fauci has been a
disaster for many reasons,
including, I think,
what Rand Paul,
Senator Rand Paul has exposed,
which is an enormous
amount of dishonesty
coming from that gentleman
and I'm, and when we retake
the House and we retake
the Senate in November,
we're going to investigate
that gentleman,
what happened in China
and what he was doing
with taxpayer funds.
But the fact is, that
man wanted to be a hero,
and you talk about
a God complex,
oh, my goodness
gracious, that man,
really, who would turn over
everything to an Anthony Fauci,
but we did.
We did it at the national level
and we did it at
the state level.
And again, there isn't
any one area of expertise
that should take precedence
during any type of a crisis.
Our economists should
have had more of a say,
our small business owners
should have had more of a say,
and I'm also gonna
go back to something
that's absolutely foundational,
which is, I don't care
what kind of a crisis
you may be facing at
that particular time,
and especially after
two or three weeks,
when we had a much
better understanding
of what was going on, six
months, even more information,
our constitution
exists for a reason.
Our First Amendment rights,
our Second Amendment rights,
our Fourth and Fifth and
14th Amendment rights
are absolutely sacrosanct.
They don't come from
government, they come from God.
They are natural rights,
they are inherent in us.
There isn't a
government out there
that has the right to dictate
that we cannot worship,
that we cannot exercise
our freedom of speech,
that we cannot exercise,
that there isn't due
process available.
So that was one of the things.
As a constitutional attorney,
I was horrified by the
willingness of people
like the governor of New
Jersey who came out and said,
adhering to the constitution
was above his pay grade.
The guy should have been
impeached right then.
I mean, if the guy
does not recognize
that his oath was to
uphold the constitution,
he should have been
out on his ear.
And the fact that we
have continued to allow
those people to really
dictate what we can do
is pretty shocking and
hopefully it's a lesson learned.
- Man, you're speaking
my language, sister.
I may have to look into an acre
somewhere in Wyoming
as a summer home.
Not a bad idea.
But I'm sure some people
are watching this going,
well, wait, Dave, even
if it's just an at,
even if it is the at-large
congressional district,
why are you talking to a
congressional candidate
from Wyoming?
It seems a little obscure
from a national perspective,
but actually, here's the bumper
sticker for this episode,
you are running against a woman
by the name of Liz Cheney.
Now, of course, Liz Cheney
has become a sort of star
amongst the CNN, MSNBC
crowd as a Republican
who pretty much is
against Republicans,
and she is obsessed
with January 6th
and the quote-unquote
"insurrection" and
everything else.
So I don't wanna
lead you too much.
I might have done it already.
Why don't you give your
feelings on Liz Cheney
and how she relates to Wyoming?
- Liz Cheney betrayed our state.
She betrayed our country.
And I'll tell you a couple
of reasons of why I say that
because I know that's a
fairly bold statement,
but that's why I made the
decision to run against her.
I've had a successful
law practice.
I've been working for
a nonprofit law firm
outta Washington,
DC, for a while.
I love the work that I do,
but there needs to be a change,
and we needed to put someone up
who had the ability
to take on Liz Cheney
and with this battle for
Wyoming and for country.
Liz Cheney, there
are several things
that are a problem with her,
including the fact
that Liz Cheney
bought a home in
Wyoming in 2012,
so that she could run for
Senate against Mike Enzi.
That imploded,
and she was not able to
pursue that any further,
and then we heard very
little from Liz Cheney
after that until 2016, when our
congressional seat came open
and she came back to
Wyoming to run for that.
Liz Cheney lives
in Washington, DC.
That's where her family, not
Washington DC, excuse me,
Northern Virginia, that's
where her family resides.
Her husband works for
a law firm back there
that does work for
China, by the way.
We can talk about
that in a moment.
Liz Cheney has very, very,
very few ties to Wyoming.
I realize that her
father represented
the state of Wyoming
over 30 years ago,
but Liz Cheney's had very
little, very few ties to Wyoming
and very little interest
in the state of Wyoming.
She talks a good game,
but if you scratch her,
what you find is she's
very, very shallow.
She's very shallow on the issues
that are so
important to Wyoming,
again, our energy issues,
our agricultural issues.
And then also the
regulatory issues.
Over 48% of our surfaces estate
is owned by the
federal government,
and 65% of our mineral
estate is owned
by the federal government,
so we have a huge
federal footprint.
And the regulations coming
outta Washington, DC
have been crushing us,
but she hasn't done much
to actually fix that.
She does not represent Wyoming
and she isn't representing
our interests.
As far as the January 6th,
I've started
describing it this way,
we have separation of
powers for a reason.
And I know she
keeps coming back to
"That are either
for the constitution
or you're for Donald Trump,
but you can't be for both."
That's a binary that
makes no sense whatsoever,
and especially as
someone who is actually
a constitution attorney,
it's actually kind of
a stupid statement,
and it's a stupid statement
for a lot of reasons,
including that it
ignores the vast,
it ignores the
constitution itself.
But here's one of the
fundamental things
I think people
need to understand
about what Liz Chaney is doing,
is, we have a
separation of powers.
The legislative branch
writes the laws,
the executive branch
carries them out,
and the judiciary
makes decisions,
from criminal law
to criminal cases,
to deciding disputes
between neighbors.
What this commission has
done is taken on the role
of all of them, but
most importantly,
this January 6th Commission
is acting as the prosecutor.
They're presenting evidence to
themselves as the judiciary,
and then they are going
to be making the decision
as the jury, so they
have actually subsumed
in themselves all aspects
of decision-making.
They will decide what
evidence comes in,
and if it doesn't fit their
narrative, we'll never see it,
it'll never see
the light of day.
The fact that they
kept, that Nancy Pelosi,
probably, most likely
with Liz Cheney's guidance
Jim Jordan from being
part of that committee
tells you from
the very beginning
that there was a narrative
that they were going to pursue,
and that's what
they're pursuing.
So Liz Cheney spends
all of her time,
she even said it a
couple of days ago--
- Do we know that
that was a fact.
I don't remember
that specifically.
Do we know for sure that
she was guiding Pelosi
in terms of keeping Jim Jordan
and some of those people
off the committee?
- I don't know that for a fact,
but keep in mind how
much she disdains--
- I think we have a lot of
reasons to believe it, yeah.
- Yeah, I think that
it's reasonable.
And the fact that she
and Adam Kinzinger
are the only two so-called
Republicans on that committee.
They didn't want a Jim
Jordan and a Jim Banks
asking questions about,
well, wait a minute,
what about security that day,
why wasn't there more security,
when did you know about this,
were there provocateurs
in the crowd
and who were those provocateurs,
were there any FBI informants,
were there FBI employees,
were there other people?
Those are the kinds of things
that are never going
to be presented
as part of this commission,
so what you've got is
you've got a prosecutor
who is going to
ignore any evidence
that doesn't support
their narrative
presenting a case to
themselves to decide
what happened on January 6th,
and so if you wanna talk
about being unconstitutional
or extra-constitutional, it
seems to me that this commission
is one of the very
first places to start.
This is a Star Chamber,
and their intent is to
come out with a report
that they can hang around
the neck of Donald Trump
and that they can
try to ostracize
those of us who support
him and conservatives
from now until the end of time.
That's the purpose
of this, we know it,
and that's what she
spends her time on,
and we're embarrassed.
She's using Wyoming
as the launchpad
to give her the
power to do that.
- What do you think her
true angle is with this?
I mean, obviously she's getting
a lot of mainstream cred, right.
They love her because
she's sort of what I call
the pet Republican.
She does whatever
the mainstream wants,
and then that's the type
of Republican they like.
And then the second she does
something that they don't like,
then they're done with her
and they pick somebody else.
But do you think her
angle is purely because,
well, perhaps what you just
said about her husband,
but also because her father
was the vice president.
He's so entrenched in the swamp
that she's just
protecting the thing,
she's protecting the DC thing,
regardless of what
the constituents may
be in Wyoming want.
I can't imagine a
lot you're hearing
when you're out there,
a lot of people going,
oh, this is the most
important issue of the day.
- Number one, it isn't
the most important issue
for the day for
people in Wyoming.
I think that there are
Democrats in Wyoming
who wanna continue
to bang that drum,
but that just further supports
the position I'm taking on this.
As far as her agenda goes,
I think that she made the
decision in the fall of 2020,
and perhaps even before that,
that this was basically a battle
between her and the President
Trump faction of the party.
She made the decision that
she was going to go after him.
And around November of 2020,
she was the very first,
especially high-up Republican,
that called president
Trump to concede,
and that the election was fine,
that there was no
problem with it.
So it was at that
point that she realized
that it was either going
to be President Trump
and his followers, or
it was going to be her.
And she started
rallying the forces,
rallying the swamp to
try to take him out.
Keep in mind, she's
the one that organized
the letter from the
secretaries of defense
saying that President
Trump was unfit for office.
Why that's really important
is that she, that issue
was issued, what that
letter was issued
prior to January 6th.
It wasn't based on what
happened on January 6th.
I believe that they issued
that letter on January 4th.
So there wasn't even
anything to point to,
so I think that she went all in,
okay, it's either Trump or
me, and that's where she is.
And I think that she thought
we're gonna take him out,
this is the kill shot, this
is gonna be the end of it,
and all they've done is
they've strengthened him
and they've exposed the swamp
and exposed themselves
for what they are.
So I don't know what
her end goal is.
I don't know what her
long-term plans are.
Being from Wyoming,
I cannot imagine
why she would do
what she's doing,
but it obviously has
to do with the fact
that people in Washington,
DC think very differently
than we do out here
in the real world.
And I think that there
is a certain sense
of protecting the
masses back there.
It is a blob.
There has been created
in Washington, DC,
a sense of entitlement and a
government in and of itself
that in many ways is not
answerable to us anymore,
and that's what I wanna go
back there and fight against.
We should not be having,
what we are finding out
about the spying
on President Trump,
both before the election
and after the election,
I, my heart hurts.
I am horrified that we are
finding out that the opposition,
that Hillary Clinton
and her minions
and the folks in the deep state
have been spying
on the president.
Regardless of which party,
I don't care if he were a
Democrat or a Republican,
I would be horrified
by what has happened.
And now we're living through
this dystopian nightmare
of not knowing if
we could even trust
our institutions right now.
That isn't the way
that I was raised.
We've always trusted
our institutions,
and Washington, DC,
has so undermined them
that, again, those of
us in the real world
are awfully skeptical about
what's happening back there,
and we're extremely
skeptical of what Liz Cheney
is doing and what
her motivations are.
- So how do we scale
some of that stuff back
'cause I think you're right,
most people at this point don't
believe in the institutions.
They feel something has
gone horrifically awry.
They feel like
what comes outta DC
has nothing to do with
their day-to-day life.
Regardless of what you
think of the events
of January 6th specifically,
I've just never met
anyone in the last year
who's really walking
around saying,
this is the biggest
issue of the day,
but they're obsessed
with this stuff
to sort of keep our
eye off the ball.
I mean, what do you think,
from a constitutional
perspective, a
legal perspective,
like, what can we do actually
to reverse the machine
a little bit and get
things back to the way
the country was
supposed to be run?
- Well, one of the things
that I've been doing
since I made the decision to run
for this office is
I have reached out
to a variety of
congressional representatives
in Washington, DC, to start
building those relationships
and the allyships
that I'm going to need
to be an effective
Congresswoman back there.
And one of the things
that I've talked
to them repeatedly about
are what my priorities are,
and my priorities are taking
power outta Washington, DC.
We need to be working
with our governors,
our good and
effective governors,
the Ron DeSantises of the world.
We need to be
working with our good
and effective attorney generals,
and we need to be
doing what was intended
by our foundational
documents, and that is,
there should be very little
power in Washington, DC,
so, even Congress.
We have got to start
divesting ourselves,
but we've really
got to be divesting
the unelected bureaucrats
of the power that they have
and that they have amassed.
Over the last 10, 15 years,
I've been traveling the country
giving a speech called
Regulation Without
Representation,
and I've been exposing
what has been happening
with our administrative state,
and that's primarily
what I've dealt with
as a trial attorney, so
I'm a trial attorney,
I've represented a lot of
landowners and business owners
against the EPA, US
Fish & Wildlife Service,
US Forest Service, USDA,
all of the alphabet
agencies, if you will,
fighting to protect our
private property rights,
fighting against their
incredible government overreach
attempting to take control of
our irrigation infrastructure
and those sorts of things.
I wanna take that expertise
to Washington, DC,
work with my fellow
congressional representatives
and find ways to
substantially impact
the power and reduce the
power that these agencies have
over the citizens
of this country.
It was never intended
to be that way.
In addition to which, there's
just such an enormous waste
associated with it.
The EPA, tens of
thousands of employees,
yet every single
state has a department
of environmental quality.
Why do we have tens of thousands
of employees in the EPA,
all of whom seem to
think that their job
is to punish people, rather
than working with our state,
our state Department of
Environmental Quality?
I get along great with
the DEQ here in Wyoming.
I'll tell you what, the
EPA and I go head-to-head,
and I've had to have
trials against him
and beat the dog out of him
in order to keep
them back from trying
to take control of my
clients' properties,
but why would the EPA be able
to come into a Worland, Wyoming,
and start attempting
to punish people
for straightening
an irrigation ditch,
if that's what they do.
We need to expose it,
we need to roll it back,
we need to bring that
power back to the states
where it belongs,
but it's Congress
that's gonna have
to act to do it.
- Yeah.
Actually, can you explain
that sort of thing
a little bit further cuz
I think a lot of people,
they still hear the EPA, the
word protection's in there,
environment, it sort
of sounds right,
okay, they must be nice
people doing these things.
As you said, there's now
thousands and thousand of people
that are part of this, but
can you gimme an example
of what type of thing would
be happening in Wyoming
where someone is living
their life as they see fit,
whatever water rights they have,
or whatever other
natural resource it is,
and what the EPA
would want to do,
why they would claim
they would wanna do it,
and then what happens when you
get into a fight with them?
- Well, I'll tell you,
I'll give you one example
of a case that I handled
up in Northern Wyoming,
and it was outside of Worland
where I was last week.
I represented a
landowner and he moved
an irrigation ditch
on his property,
and the EPA, and I know
it was a test case,
they came in and
claimed that he violated
the Clean Water
Act by doing that
because that irrigation
ditch was a, quote,
"navigable water of
the United States."
It wasn't, it was
an irrigation ditch,
he had the right to maintain it
and to move it and
do what he did.
It took us six years.
They filed the enforcement
action against him in 2008.
We finally had a
two-week trial in 2014.
I'm smart enough to know that
you always get a jury trial
when you're going up against
the federal government
for many reasons, but one
is that a lot of judges
anymore are federal employee,
I mean, they are
federal employees,
and they think of
themselves that way,
so I had a jury and after
a two-week jury trial,
they came back and ruled
in my client's favor.
He affected 2.1
acres on his own land
in cleaning up what had been
a terrible disaster, actually.
Everybody had kind
of abused that farm
cuz it had been leased by
absentee farmers for many years.
He took out, he's an engineer,
and so he designed
a beautiful channel
through there to make sure
that the water could flow,
reduce sedimentation, reduce
any type of chemigation
going into the Bighorn River
and that sort of thing.
At one point, by
moving 2.1 acres,
by affecting 2.1 acres
on his own property,
he was facing penalties
of $65 million
because the EPA claims that
they can impose penalties,
at that time, of $37,500 a day,
that has now gone
up to $59,000 a day,
if you violate the
Clean Water Act.
So what they do is they
come into these farmers
or ranchers and they say, you
violated the Clean Water Act,
you're facing penalties
of $59,000 a day
unless you do exactly
what we tell you to do.
Well, obviously, two
days, you're dead broke,
so nobody can fight
back against them,
and that's the thing,
is that Congress
never should have given
that kind of authority
to a bureaucracy because
giving a bureaucracy
that kind of
punishment authority,
they turn into dictators and
that's what they've done.
So right now I'm
handling a lawsuit.
I don't know if you
remember when the EPA
blew out the Gold King Mine
in southwestern Colorado
and they turned the
Animas River orange.
It was in 2015.
You can Google it.
It was one of the worst
environmental disasters
in our country's history,
and the EPA did it.
So they went in and without
my client's permission
or knowledge, they built
a water treatment facility
on his property,
they've operated it
for six and a half years and
never paid him a dime in rent.
It's an unconstitutional
takings.
That's the kind of
abuse that the EPA
visits upon our
landowners every day.
What the EPA is trying to do
is they'd like to take control
of all water resources
in this country.
We know what happens when
the federal government
takes control of anything,
especially when it is a
resource such as water
that is absolutely
necessary for life.
You know what happens.
We're seeing it
with medical care.
They're saying, okay, you
don't get the vaccine,
we're gonna take away your job,
we're gonna take away
your unemployment,
your medical care.
That's exactly what
they're moving on,
and they have been
moving on with water.
This is no longer any
kind of a conspiracy idea.
This is truly what the
federal government does.
One of the most horrific
things that happened
in this country was Obamacare
because that's when the
federal government decided
that they could control
our decision making
by controlling our
access to healthcare,
and look at what they've done
to us in the last two years.
They wanna do the
same thing with water.
- I have two personal friends,
I tell people all the time,
who were doctors
before Obamacare, who
are no longer doctors
because they got sick
of doing paperwork,
so how much more do
you possibly wanna know
after you've spent
all that money
to go to medical school
and everywhere else?
One of the things I've been
asking a lot of my guests
over the last two months or so,
especially since I've
moved to Florida,
that's been on my mind a lot is,
what do you see as
sort of the future
of the United States of America?
I mean, I think
one silver lining
perhaps in these
last two crazy years
is that people have
started to move to states
that are more in line
with their values,
they're thinking about their
life a little more seriously.
I think there's good
reasons for that,
and that's what
federalism is all about,
I don't have to tell
you obviously, but
on the other hand,
I think that's very scary to
people because then it's like,
well, what makes us united?
Do you have a vision for that?
I mean, if we all just go in
our separate ways and say,
the values of Wyoming
will be much more similar
to what I'm living
here in Florida,
but that's gonna be
very different than
New York and Cali.
What keeps us united
at that point?
- Well, I think that
the constitution
and our foundational
documents keep us united,
but it's okay for people
to have different views
of the world.
I don't have any office to that.
I know that there are
people who disagree with me
and I'm perfectly
cool with that.
But as you say, we can
vote with our feet,
and we can go places
that are more aligned
with us politically, but even
if you don't have the ability
to do that, I'll tell you what,
my heroes right now
are the parents,
those parents that are
fighting back to protect
their babies from these
horrible mask mandates,
from the things that
they've done to our schools.
These people are heroes.
And I have said for a long time
with the work that I've done,
when I started giving my speech,
Regulation Without
Representation,
our debt was around
$13 trillion.
It's now $30 trillion,
and I've been watching it go
up and up and up, we all have,
but I've been watching
it in real time
because I a lot about it
and how there's
an interconnection
between what is going on in
DC with these bureaucracies,
with the outta control spending,
with Congress largely abdicating
its responsibility for
legislating and that debt,
and we're the largest debtor
nation in world history,
and that trajectory
has got to change,
and I've for a long time,
we're gonna have to really
suffer before things get better,
and I feel that way and
I wish it wasn't true.
I've tried to sound
the warning bells.
I've tried to tell people,
we can't keep going
down this road
and expect that we're
going to prosper.
You can't attack everything
that makes you prosperous
and expect that it's
still going to be there
when you need it to
continue that prosperity,
yet that's where we are.
We've got the socialists saying,
we've gotta take over
our energy companies
and do this and that.
Yeah, that's not gonna
work well for anybody,
and we all know that.
We all know how that story ends.
So it is a matter of people
standing up for their rights.
I am very optimistic
because people,
after what the government
has done to them
at the, both the state
and federal level
has done to them in
the last two years,
we're rising up and
we're saying enough,
and when we go back
to Congress this time,
we're not protecting
the status quo.
We've got 30 to 40 years
of really bad policies
that we're gonna
have to roll back.
We're not protecting
the status quo,
and if the Republicans
go in there
and protect the status
quo, we've failed.
- Do you think
that the Democrats,
and even sort of
the pet Republicans
that are keeping
this thing going
as we have this sort of
breakdown of the supply chain
and crazy inflation
and all of the stuff
that we've talked about,
do you think they think
they're doing good?
I mean, do you think
that the people
in the administration
actually believe
that they're doing
the right thing
as they see all of the breakdown
of basic services
and everything else?
- You know, that's a very
interesting question.
What I would say about it is
that I think that dictators
in general often think that
they're doing the right thing
because they think that
they're always right.
And the reality is
that they aren't.
That's why we have the
form of government we do.
It's why we have the
separation of powers,
why it's the executive branch
that is to carry out the
law, not make the law.
So I think from that standpoint,
I'm not sure that they
think that they're doing
the right thing, but
one of the of things
that you find with people
who actually believe
in socialism or moving down
that type of government,
they're the elitist
who don't believe
that they're the ones that
will have to live under it,
and all we have to look
at are the mask mandates
and the people who won't
wear masks right now.
All of the, we refer
to them as hypocrites.
I actually don't like that word
because I don't think
that it really encompasses
the, what they've done,
which is, there's rules
for thee and not for me.
And there's a lot of
countries in the world
where that is how they're run
and they are not run well,
and it's why we don't
wanna live there.
We are the most prosperous,
the most free country
in the history of the world
because we have to all
live by the rule of law.
We're all supposed to
live by the same rules.
And if you don't wanna
live by those rules,
then don't make 'em
for other people.
And so we now have a
segment of society,
and I refer to them, I
guess, as the elitist,
although I don't even think
that that encompasses it,
but they are the
people who think
that they should tell
Harriet Hageman what to do,
pretty much all day every day.
My own parents didn't
tell me what to do
when I was three
and four years old.
That's what I started out
this conversation with.
They let me do what
I wanted to do,
but they constantly talked
about the responsibility
of keeping myself alive as well.
Responsibility and
freedom go hand in hand.
What these people wanna do
is take away our freedom.
And I don't know that I can
always get in their head,
but I think that we've got
an awful lot of examples
of how their form of government
and their ideas and
their ideals fail.
All we have to do is
look at Venezuela,
and Venezuela is a
perfect real-time example
of what happens
when the government
wants to tell you every
aspect of your life,
and that's why
the last two years
have been so frightening
for people like you and I,
because we know the government
doesn't know better than we do.
I've got great
nieces and nephews
that are five or six years old,
they'll go out, they'll work
all day long on horseback,
and you know what,
those kids can take care of
themselves in a lot of ways,
and they don't need
Nancy Pelosi or Joe Biden
or AOC or Liz Cheney telling
them from Washington, DC,
how to live their lives.
They do a pretty
doggone good job of it.
- Well, I can tell you from
living in Miami for a month,
I got plenty of Venezuelan
and Cuban neighbors
and they know exactly what
they fled in the first place,
or usually what their
parents or grandparents fled,
- Right.
- In the first place.
I'm curious, backing up to
the election specifically,
your election specifically,
what kind of support or
non-support are you getting
from just sort of the
main Republican machine,
because obviously this fight
between sort of, let's
say, swamp Republicans,
or just sort of the more
mainstream Republicans,
whatever that is, whatever
phrase you want to use,
versus sort of the Trump-wing.
That still is an internal fight
that Republicans
or conservatives
have to figure out.
- You know, I think it's
somewhat of an internal fight,
but not one that I necessarily
acknowledge most of the time,
because I still
believe that most of us
believe exactly the same thing,
which, the Republicans need
to be the party of freedom.
We need to be the party
of the constitution.
We need to be the
party of recognizing
that individuals are
responsible for themselves,
and it isn't for the
government to step in
and dictate everything we do.
We have moved down the
road of collectivism
in this country in a
pretty frightening way,
and all Republicans need to
be pushing back against that,
heck, Democrat should be too,
but I don't know why they don't,
but really, the
Republicans in Wyoming,
I've had an enormous
amount of support,
and we have a broad spectrum
of Republicans in Wyoming,
from being very liberal to
being very conservative,
and I have a huge
amount of support
as I travel around the state.
I've been extremely
pleased with how people
have reached out to me
and responded to me.
From a national standpoint, I
think the same thing as well.
I consider myself to
be a conservative,
but everything I've
talked about today
really defines who I am,
and so if that's what people
think is conservative,
or if they think
that that's moderate,
however they wanna
view it, they can.
I've kind of given
you a pretty good idea
how I view the world and
how I view our country,
and a lot of people are really
hungry for that message,
and they're really
hungry to understand
that there's someone
who's willing
to go back to Washington, DC,
and fight this battle for them.
And I can tell you that I am.
I'm willing to go back
there and do whatever I can
to turn this ship around
because we need to.
We have been so
fortunate in our lives.
We have been so fortunate in
what we've been able to do.
Like I talked about,
I came from a very,
very humble beginning,
and now I'm running for Congress
because in the United States,
you have the freedom
to succeed that way.
Our granddaughters, our
nieces, our nephews,
our great nieces, our
nephews, our children,
all of them have the
absolute same right
that we have had to pursue
those types of endeavors.
We can't take it away from 'em.
We owe it to the next
generation, and I'm
fighting for them.
I'm fighting for
my granddaughters.
Jasmine and Kaylee.
I'm fighting for
everybody in my family.
I come from a huge family.
I'm fighting for
everybody in Wyoming
and for this country to return
to really our foundation
of who we are and what has
made this country so great.
- Harriet, you're the
type of politician we need
cuz I can tell, you don't
even wanna be a politician,
which is exactly what the
point is in the first place,
and because my last question
was basically gonna throw it
to you to say whatever you want
and give the final sales pitch,
but I think you just
did it right there
unless you got anything else.
Where can we send people
if they wanna find
out more about you?
- Hagemanforwyoming.com.
There's a lot of information,
and Liz Cheney has an
awful lot of money.
If anybody wants to
support me and help us out
to take this message, not
only statewide, but nationally
and make sure that we
return people to Congress
or put people in Congress
who are gonna fight
for the everyday man cuz
it's the everyday man
that has made this
country as great as it is.
So I love the opportunity
to visit with you.
I hope I can come back cuz
you're a lot of fun to talk to.
I can assure you, when I
go back to Washington, DC,
I'm taking everything
that is Wyoming with me
and I'm really looking
forward to serve the people.
- Well, I enjoy talking to you,
and I'm not really kidding
about maybe an acre
in Wyoming for the summer,
so we may have to talk.
I sense you might know
a real estate agent.
- We would love
to have you here.
We'd love to have you here.
I'll take you up.
If you watch my video,
Ride For The Brand,
which is on our website,
and that's the ranch
that I grew up on.
Those are my family members.
That's where I come from.
I think it gives you an
idea of who and what I am.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.